4 milliards d'êtres humains le dernier
adieu à la reine elliizabeth sera suivi
dans le monde entier les funérailles de
celle-ci qui aura régné jusqu'à et bien
il y a 10 jours 70 ans très précisément
le ciel est gris à Londres la
température est à peine de 12°gr c'est
le dernier péricle bonjour bienvenue il
est 11h33 les images vous les avez en
direct je dis bonjour à mon plateau
d'abord ceux qui vont nous expliquer ce
qui va se passer aujourd'hui is schith
Isabelle Schmith je montre le Figaro
série vous êtes la rédactrice en chef
adjointe de ce magazine que vous pouvez
retrouver en kiosque Victor Bouri
bonjour directeur général de bagbone un
sondage très intéressant sur ce que
pensent les les Français de la de la
royauté Catherine fieski directrice du
think tank counterp hein c'est ça
spécialiste de la politique au
Royaume-Uni et puis Pascal un
journaliste à Madame Figaro les images
en direct avec vous le voyez la famille
royale qui arrive à à Westminster Hall
c'est très précis tout va être réglé
tout va être réglé au au millimètre eu
Isabelle c'est c'est une journée pas
comme les autres he là le le monde
entier regarde le monde entier regarde
le peuple anglais a attendu plus de 24
heures en moyenne par personne pour
aller rendre un dernier hommage à sa
souveraine et on peut penser au mot de
que le poète Charles pegy imagine à la
mort de saintjn viev quand il imagine le
peuple français qui pleure celle qu'il
avait cru éternelle l'amour de tout un
peuple était tout son cortège bien là
pour la pour la reine Élisabeth c'est le
cas en Angleterre et c'est le cas aussi
depuis nos pays qui ne sont pour la
plupart plus des monarchies et qui
pourtant sont fascinés euh par C ce
l'enterrement de cette souveraine qui
est sans doute un un symbole qui a
marqué son siècle à l'évidence et qui et
qui jusque dans son
enterrement donne un signal d'un temps
qui semble assez éloigné duune autre et
qui pourtant nous rejoint et nous touche
les imag en direct depuis l'abaye de
Westminster on a vu arriver les les
principaux dirigeants g du monde entier
on a vu notamment Joe Biden on a vu
Emmanuel Macron accompagné de de
Brigitte Macron évidemment vous voyez
ces arrivé qui qui continue alors 11h35
c'est le moment où le cercueil
d'Élizabeth et bien sera soulevé du du
catafalque de Westminster Hall avant
d'aller vers vers donc l'abbaye
Pascaline poevin c'est un moment PIP
aujourd'hui et d'ailleurs on le voit
regardez Camila la reine conur qui
arrive également sur les sur les lieux
des des funérailles oui un moment
important dans cette histoire cette
histoire d'une famille qu'on suit depuis
toujours qu'on suit euh on le sait parce
que c'est un compte de faée c'est
vraiment une histoire de reine de roi de
princesse de Prince avec des mariages
des enterrements on suit comme ça chaque
étape de leur vie parce qu'elle nous
connecte quelque part à ce cette
fascination qu'on a et qu'on aura
toujours pour les comptes de fé
aujourd'hui l'enterrement de d'Élisabeth
BO est important dans la l'histoire de
la famille royale en ce sens que c'est
une famille qui a besoin d'être unie et
de montrer à nouveau qu' qu'elle estunie
elle a été secouée par de nombreux
scandales ces dernières années je pense
que les images qu'on va voir aujourd'hui
sont vraiment pour elle l'occasion de
montrer qu'à nouveau les rangs se
resserrent vous réagissez évidemment sur
Le Figaro.fr sur Youtube on va vous
donner plein de chiffres ils sont très
impressionnants évidemment Victor bourri
les Français se fascinent ou pas
de funérailles de du décès
malheureusement de de re les Français
fascine ça fait longtemps que la reine
est dans le cœur des Français il y a eu
plusieurs sondages même dans les années
auparavant aujourd'hui le sondage qui
éta réalisé la semaine dernière le
confirme les Français aiment la reine un
peu moins le roi et ce qu'on a vu
surtout ce qui assez intéressant en
terme d'analyse de l'opinion c'est que
le le le décès de laarine on l'a vu sur
les réseaux sociaux a cré une émotion
gigantesque et c'est dans dans le casre
la rité la monarchie britannique est
intéressant parce que ça fait plusieurs
années ils étaient les premiers à
adopter la famille roal à adopter les
réseaux sociaux pour s'exprimer d'cord
outre passant les médias traditionnel
avec qui ils avaient des échanges
souvent interview c'est ça donc c'est un
bon moyen de communication ils ont pu
ils ils ont pu autrepasser les médias
traditionnels et ça se traduit
aujourd'hui il y y a un flot vraiment
énorme sur les réseaux sociaux
d'affection d'émotions qui diffèrent en
en fonction des pays mais dans
l'ensemble depuis la mort de de la ren
on a plus de 67 millions de messag
échangés ce qui est ce qui est colossal
et dans l'ensemble des pays avec
peut-être une remarque assez
intéressante et qui on on on le verra se
confirmera ou non sur le plan politique
dans l'exercice de la fonction du roi
c'est le fait que dans les pays du
Commonwealth a eu moins d'émotion que
dans les autres pays par rapport si on
prend à la France par exemple vous nous
voyons regardez cette affu Canon alors
c'est très intéressant
Isabelle tout est
aujourd'hui on fait appel au passé hein
si je se dire he le symbole dans chaque
instant hein absolument cet affu de
canon qui
avait servi pour la reine Victoria et
qui et qui sera tiré aujourd'hui par 142
marins de la Navy oui c'est ça alors ce
sont pas des chevaux alors ce ne sont
pas des chevaux parce que lors de
l'enterrement de la reine Victoria les
chevaux c'étaient dangereusement
emballés c'est ça et donc on a préféré
faire tirer cette affu de canon par des
marins à l'avant et à l'arrière ils sont
142 et parmi eux je lisais en non pas
parmi ceux-l mais je lisais le
témoignage de l'une d'entre eux qui
était vétéran de de la Marine et qui
disait que dans dans les combats les
plus violents qu'elle avait eu elle
avait toujours été poussée par le
sentiment de se battre pour l' reine ce
qui pour nous républicain est quelque
chose de de touchant d'étonnant euh cela
me rappel quand quand Victor vous
évoquiez la popularité d'éliisabeth II
auprès des Français ça me rappelle une
anecdote que racontait Stéphane Berne
lorsqu'il l'a rencontré à l'ambassade de
Grande-Bretagne à Paris et qui lui
disait vous avez vu toute la foule qui
est massée pour vous devant elle disait
oui je sais je fais toujours cet effet
au au pays
républicain vous voyez ici Kate
Middleton qui arrive à l'abay avant que
bien vous savez les les femmes vont
directement à l'abaye et puis ce seront
les les hommes le roi évidemment et ses
fils qui suivront le le cortège le State
gun funeral carriage de la Royal Navy
alors ça a été utilisé pour les
transports des cercueils de laarine
Victoria du roi Edouard VI du roi George
VI de Win Winston Churchill voilà on le
sort que pour les pour les grandes
occasions on écoute ce qui se passe un
petit peu à Londres et puis on revient
en plateau et et je viens vers vous euh
Catherine fiki évidemment
[Musique]
de recueillement évidemment devant
Westminster Hall Catherine fiki moment
important pour le Royaume-Uni avec des
chefs d'État du monde entier et puis
toute la classe politique qui sera là
également exactement un moment important
alors pense un vrai moment de de faire
un moment de deuil mais aussi un moment
de
rassemblement dans un pays qui a quand
même été extrêmement secoué ces
dernières années par le brexit par le
covid des moments difficiles au sein du
gouvernement et je pense qu'il y a aussi
ce qui caractérise ces ces journées
c'est ce sont des journées de certitude
finalement les choses sont rythmées là
ce ces funérailles ce sont des
funérailles qui sont scriptés en quelque
sorte et je pense que pour les Brit
il ils savent il subodor quelque part
que ça va être les derniers moments qui
sont véritablement scriptés après avant
un grand moment d'incertitude vous voyez
le le cercueil qui sort en ce moment
même de Westminster Hall qui va être
déposé devant cette affu canon tiré
ensuite par 142 marins alors 90 tirs et
les autres freinent Isabelle voilà pour
pour tout préciser on écoute peut-être
ce moment et puis on revient ici en
plateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
[Musique]
11h45 léger retard sur le protocole on n
avait dit que tout était millimétré
cette AFF canon devait partir à 11h44 et
bien nous allons voir si le retard est
rattrapé ça y est c'est parti C affu de
canon qui se dirige donc avec le
cercueil de la reine ellizabeth vers
l'abbaye de Westminster Arnaud de
larange vous êtes notre correspondant à
Londres lond qui aujourd'hui est
complètement bouclé hein c'est ça Arnaud
oui ben Londres a pris on a l'impression
que toute la planète c'est c'est c'est
pressé à Londres en tout cas pour pour
les grandes ceonde hein on l'a vu de Joe
Biden à Emmanuel Macron au tête couronné
à l'entire du Japon donc il a il y a il
y a évidemment tout cet aspect déjà sur
sur sur les puissants de ce monde avec
tout tout le Castet sécuritaire qu'il y
a derrière et puis la foule de manière
générale des centaines de milliers de
personnes est-ce que ça sera 1 million
est-ce que ce sera plus voilà en tout
cas Londres est un peu en état de siège
et évidemment vous imaginez que la
circulation y est très compliquée oui
alors l'émotion racontez-moi est-ce que
pendant 10 jours l'émotion est monté
jusqu'à bien aujourd'hui ces funérailles
qui mine de rien étent attendu depuis
plusieurs années tout est prévu au
millimètre hein Arnaud
oui vous vous vous vous avez raison
c'està-dire que tout était vraiment
prévu organisé n rien laissé au hasard
et on voit bien d'ailleurs en parleraai
j'imagine déjà enfin vous en avez déjà
parlé il y a il y a toute une dans dans
dans
l'organisation la procession des
événements il y a il y a des il y a un
souci dans le détail mais dans le détail
qui n'est pas gratuit qui n'est pas
uniquement du décorum c'estàdire qu'il y
a des la force des symboles derrière qui
font appel à l'histoire mais aussi qui
donneent des signaux vis-à-vis du futur
notamment par exemple sur l'unité du
royaume voilà donc tout ça a été prévu
millimétré ça n'empêche pas qu'il y a
aussi après la part d'émotion qui est là
et oui elle est montée même si ça paraît
long 10 jours et elle est montée
notamment avec cette fameuse que cette
d'attente absolument incroyable pour
pour se devant le cercueil d'Élisabeth
et qui qui qui ne s'est qui n'a été
arrêté que ce matin à à 6h à 6h30 ce
matin donc il y a il y a une émotion
très forte qui dépasse évidemment tout
ce qui s'est passé certainement
aujourd'hui comme événement royal et on
aura certainement les les chiffres de
tout ça et tout ça va se mesurer dans
les jours qui viennent mais c'est vrai
que c'est assez c'est assez
impressionnant quand même de de voir
cela même si on sait que cela va arriver
même si on est préparé c'est assez c'est
c'est assez troublant et impressionnant
de de voir cette cette cette ferveur et
cette communion du peuple britannique
qu'on peut certains on sourit il
n'empêche elle est là et et elle n'est
pas feinte 11h48 nous sommes toujours en
direct vous voyez le roi Charles 3 qui
suit le le cercueil de sa mère Arnaud
pardonnez-moi cette question est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est une journée de
deuil ou une journée de
fête non c'est je pense qu'on là
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans la
séquence dans la séquence deuil on voit
voit bien d'ailleurs au visage grave
euh évidemment il y a tout ce qui se
passe à Londres aujourd'hui enfin ce
matin pardon enfin qui est en train de
se se dérouler et et avec avec cet
enterrement encore une fois enfin ces
funérailles pardon C espèce de funéraill
devant devant le monde entier il y aura
après la deuxième partie qui se passera
au château de windnsor à une trentaine
de kilomètres de de Londres avec une
partie qui sera encore un peu publicque
et après ce soir l'inumation de la reine
euh dans dans dans dans le la chapelle
du mémorial de George 6 là il n'y aura
que la famille royale donc ça sera
certainement un moment d'intensité
familiale assz forte on est dans le
deuil il n'empêche qu'on a beau être
dans le deuil oui on se projette aussi
quand même dans l'avenir et on serut les
pas du du du du du du roi Charles II
dont on peut noter d'ailleurs que en 10
jours dans ces 10 jours de deuil c'est
ça qui est étonnant on est à la fois
dans le deuil mais vous avez raison on
est aussi dans l'avenir la popularité de
Charles I a complètement bondi elle
atteint 70 % a priori selon un dernier
sondage youov là de d'aujourd'hui alors
qu'on était à il était à 40 % et
quelques il y a avant le décès de sa
mère donc il y a apparemment une très
bon un très bon accueil de la population
britannique de la façon dont Charles I
euh fait ses premiers pas euh VO de C
merci Arnaud je vous laisse retourner à
au suivi de de cette cérémonie vous
suivez évidemment ça avec nous et puis
vous écrivez vos papiers vos articles
qu'on retrouve demain matin dans dans le
Figaro Pascaline euh on voit là le le
roi derrière le le cercueil ça nous
rappelle des images he toujours cette
famille royale le roi qui était prince à
l'époque en 1997 avec ses deux fils ouai
ça nous rappelle immanquablement aussi
les images de bah de l'enterement de la
princesse Diana les images qui avaient
marqué le monde entier euh qui avait
frappé différemment parce qu'il y avait
vraiment une surprise et une brutalité à
l'époque parce que les opinions aussi
étaient très
divisées la le monde était derrière la
princesse Diana et a était très critique
envers la famille royale qui avait mis
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à réagir et
beaucoup de temps à manifester sa
compassion à manifester son affection
entre guillemets pour pour la princesse
Diana donc cette image avait là aussi
euh participer à redorer un peu le
blason de la famille royale là on est
dans des circonstances totalement
différentes comme l'a dit ARN de
laagrange on est vraiment dans un moment
d'unité totale je pense que les Anglais
aujourd'hui même ceux qui sont critiques
par rapport à la monarchie vont marquer
un temps de respect et quoi qu'il arrive
que ce soit pour ou contre la monarchie
en Angleterre aujourd'hui on a que la
monarchie en tête et que la reine
Elisabeth
la reine pardon ellisabeth en tête donc
ça crée une unité je pense symbolisée
aussi par bah ce nouveau roi qui marche
derrière le cercle Victor bour de bbon
Consulting justement on parle de la
popularité les les Français ont l'air de
l'aimer cette reine et cette royauté
mais est-ce qu'ils en voudrai en France
pas vraiment c'est bien mais chez les
autres non c'est ça s qu' y a il y a a
une vraie émotion affection la reine une
popularité qui incontestable de Lord de
85 % des des Français lors de no sondage
la semaine dernière un peu moins pour le
roi mais effectivement en France aussi à
l' bondit de 41 % à 55 % également d'c
mais ce qui ce qui est assez intéressant
si on si on on élargit le spectre de
l'analyse de l'opinion dans le monde et
qui contribue à cette mondialisation de
l'émotion qu'on qu'on qu'on voit ici
c'est aussi lié à un facteur qui est la
série de Crown qui en fait a invité
laarine et la famille royale dans tous
les foyers du monde on beaucoup parlé
depuis depuis 10 jours sur ce plateau à
chaque fois ça revient bah ça revient
parce que c'est ce qui a permis à à la
famille Roy notamment auprès des plus
jeunes et ce qui ce qui est un outil de
de de en fait de préservation de la
enfin et de pérenité de la de la
présence à l'esprit de la famille royale
britannique chez les Français notamment
chez les plus jeunes on le voit on VO il
y a des il y a des posts sur certains
réseau sociau sur TikTok notamment d'une
influenceuse en Indonésie qui a fait
près de 10 millions de vues et qui
étaient partagé partout dans le monde
donc littéralement la reinene et la
famille s'est invité aujourd'hui dans
tout l'ensemble des foyers français
cette procession du cercueil d'Élisabeth
II la couronne posée sur le le dessus
avec ses 140 de marins qui tireent cette
affu de canon les les cornemuses et les
tambours écossais et irlandais 200 son
musiciens on écoute et on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
regarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cercueil qui arrive devant l'abaye de
Westminster où se tiendra dans quelques
instants dans à peine 7 minutes la
cérémonie au sein de de cette abbaye
Isabel Schmith tout a été calibré tout
est millimétré tout ce qui se passe là
c'est la reine qui le voulait hein oui
c'est la reine qui le voulait c'est la
reine qui a insisté pour être enterré à
que sa messe d'enterrement soit célébrée
à Westminster AB non pas à
saint-georgees comme ça avait été le cas
pour les les souverains précédents pour
en tout cas une une raison qui est le le
fait que cet abaye peut accueillir 2200
personnes oui c'est ça ça av pas été
fait depuis 1760 il ça na pas été fait
depuis 1760 et puis il y a peut-être
aussi une raison personnelle mais ça on
ne le saura jamais c'est c'est c'est là
où elle a été couronnée et là où elle
s'est marié et donc il y avait peut-être
aussi un attachement tout particulier à
cette abbaye il me semble que on on
parlait tout à l'heure des des
funérailles de la Prin Prin Diana là il
y a une grosse différence c'est que l'on
voit les insignes royaux sur le cercueil
de la reine et c'est vrai que cela prend
un sens particulier quand on sait que le
2 juin 1953 dans cette abaylie elle a
été couronnée de cette couronne elle a
reçu les deux CPRE pouvoir elle a reçu
l'orbe que l'on voit aujourd'hui sur sur
le cercueil et symbole que va recevoir
également Charles I donc cela illustre
absolument la continuité de la monarchie
et c'est peut-être aussi pour cela que
que cette cette cérémonie nous touche
c'est queelle elle nous donne l'image la
vraie image d'une continuité du pouvoir
et d'un temps long Catherine fiask je
vous je vous donne la parole il savent
faire les Britanniques parce qu'ils nous
ont tenu en haleine depuis 10 jours ou
presque sans que ce soit voyuriste et en
contradiction en miroir peut-être avec
la grandeur qui n'est plus qu'étaé du
Royaume-Uni finalement je crois que
c'est un petit peu le rôle de la
monarchie n'est-ce pas de de d'être un
petit peu le refuge théâtral du pouvoir
je pense que ça joue un rôle très
important il y a une véritable
séparation entre le gouvernement un
gouvernement qui se veut euh en tout cas
plus plus rattaché aux réalités
quotidienne quand on va à Downing Street
Downing Street ce ne sont pas des
appartements très riches la pompe le
théâtre l'apparat le décorum
appartiennent véritablement à la
monarchie pour que euh tout ce qui est
affaire gouvernemental soit beaucoup
plus proche et beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus proche du public et beaucoup plus
dénudé plus efficace en quelque sorte et
je pense aussi que c'est important pour
nous républicains cette continuité du
pouvoir dont vous avez parlé le fait
qu'il n'y ait aucun yatus the queen is
dead long live the king donc
effectivement le de
traduire la reine est morte vive le Roi
vive le Roi cette continuité cette
absence tot de vide c'est quelque chose
qui peut nous paraître important et et
en quelque sorte réconfortant lorsque
nous on a l'habitude effectivement de
gouvernements qui sont plus marqués par
les temps morts les temps longs les
vides voilà est-ce que ça plaît aux
Français justement ça cette longévité
nous on a l'habitude en France d'avoir
bah 5 ans un président 10 pourquoi pas
les Français en pensent quoi ça est-ce
que c'est pas trop Victor Bour pour les
Français majorité de Français le le
sujet c'est que la la monarchie pour eux
à 55 % elle n'est plus adaptée à
mondneàraent c'est vraiment
l'information qu'on peut retenir c'est
qu'il y a comme on le précisait tout à
l'heure un attachement émotionnel à la
reine et à la famille pour pour pour ce
qu'elle est rentré dans dans le foyer
français mais en revanche sur sur le
principe de la monarchie même adapté à
la société on sent qu'il y a une vraie
érosion de la monarchie britannique
aussi autre re chiffre marquant de notre
étude c'est que 65 % des Français
considèrent que l'essai de la reine est
avant tout une actualité people donc une
saga qui a aussussi lié au sujet de de
Crown et que c'est pas un sujet ni
politique et surtout qui prend un une
place trop importante dans les médias
aujourd'hui le cercueil d'Élisabeth I
qui entre qui entre dans Westminster
l'abaye de de Westminster alors le le
placement est très important par
qu'Aline là j'ai vu que évidemment il
aura la famille royale au premier rang
et puis après tout est calculé tout est
millimétré pour vexer personnees aucun
chef d'État que personne ne se retrouve
derrière un poteau Emmanuel Macron a
même demandé par exemple de ne pas venir
dans le bus avec avec les les autres
chefs d'État Joe Biden lui a eu le droit
à avoir the beast sa limousine pour ne
pas venir avec les autres tout est
millimétré là aussi ouais tout est
millimétré en fait cet événement moi
c'est c'est c'est THE place to be
au-delà de de la pompe de la solenité de
l'événement de la gravité de la
tristesse c'est vraiment c'est un
événement people c'est un événement de
politique people où je pense que tous
les chefs d'État rêvit peut-être d'avoir
leur invitation on a quand même t su sur
les plus sains enfin ce qu'on appelle
qui va venir accompagner comment et tout
c'est quand même un petit peu on parle
quand même d'un enterrement mais voilà
il y a une autre dimension et
effectivement tout a été pensé pour pour
que tel chef d'État ne soit pas à côté
de celui avec qui il est peut-être en
froid qui aurait la préédence c'est
vraiment un événement people et
diplomatique à la fois mais important
parce que c'est ce sont des images qui
marquent et qui vont rester on parlait
de continuité ces images là on les verra
encore longtemps dans l'histoire comme
on a pu voir les images de l'enterrement
de la princesse Diana donc c'est
important d'y être et surtout à quelle
place on y est 11h59 moment de grande
solennité le cercueil de la ren entre
dans l'abille de Westminster où ont pris
place des dizaines des centaines de
chefs d'État où ont pris place les
représentants de la famille royale nous
allons suivre ça en direct et nous
écoutons ce qui se passe à laabille de
Westminster
[Musique]
Z
je
[Musique]
Tu
și
[Musique]
and the
CH
destroy his body
[Musique]
my
i
my for
myself and my
[Musique]
shall
na
[Musique]
le
Lord
[Musique]
no
STR si Pr
[Musique]
š
moimē
[Musique]
spēēas
mū
[Musique]
ā
dāos
[Musique]
mažižījosvē
č
[Musique]
SN
S
[Musique]
słąceu
Jesus
s
[Musique]
fr
AMEN
h
[Musique]
Mo
fr
[Musique]
se
lit
problem
[Musique]
ă
for
[Musique]
from
des devoirs sacrés
ici où la reine Élisabeth s'est mariée
elle fut couronné nous sommes venus de
tous les co du
pays et du monde entier pleurer notre
perte et commémorer sa longue vie de
service et nous la soumett en confiance
la grâce de Dieu notre Créateur et notre
Rédempteur grâce à son engagement
inébranlable envers sa mission pendant
tant
d'années en tant que reine et chef du
Common c'est avec admiration que nous
nous rappelons son sens du devoir et le
dévouement qu'elle a montré à son
peuple avec reconnaissance louons le
Seigneur pour son exemple constant de
foi
chrétienne AC amé nous rappelons son
amour pour sa famille son engagement
pour les causes qui lui étaient
chèes maintenant en silence
rappelons-nous dans nos cœurs et dans
nos esprits toutes les raisons de lui
rendre
grâce prions pour tous les membres de sa
famille et confions la reine ellisabeth
à la garde de Dieu not
toutpuissant
Dieu
miséricordieux le Père de notre Seigneur
JésusChrist qui est la résurrection et
la
vie en qui vivra quiconque
croit et quiconque V et croit en Lui
connaîtra la vie
éternelle qui nous igne par son apôtre
sa pas plaindre les
incroyants humblement nous te prionons
au père de nous élever du péché vers une
vie de
justice afin que dans la mort nous
reposions en
lui comme nous l'espérons pour notre
sœur ici
présente et qu'au dernier jour de sa
résurrection nous soyons acceptables à
ses yeux
recevons cette bénédiction que ton fils
biené prononcera pour tous ceux qui
t'aiment et te
craignent disent venez enfant bénis du
père recevez le royaume qui était pour
vous dès le
commencement nous te prions au Père
miséricordieux d'accorder ceci à travers
Jésus-Christ notre médiateur et notre
Rédempteur
AMEN
[Musique]
révérent David Oy qui vient d'ouvrir
cette messe à Westminster à l'abaye de
Westminster Hélène de lausin vous nous
avez rejoint merci d'être ici euh on le
sait hein ce n'est pas une messe
catholique au ro anglican vous pouvez
nous expliquer un peu peut-être les
différences oui alors effectivement euh
euh la création de l'anglicanisme prend
sa place dans le contexte plus général
de la réforme même si c'est sur des
modalités très particulières alors
évidemment on connaît tous la figure un
peu truculante d'Henry VII et de ses
aventures sentimentales un peu
compliquées euh au départ lui c'est
plutôt au début de la Réforme il est
plutôt pro catholique en fait euh face à
Luther tout ce qui se passe en Allemagne
il écrit même ce qu'il aime beaucoup
écrire pour des FO Colque mais c'est ces
histoires effectivement avec ces
différentes femmes qui vont l'amener à
faire la rupture avec Rome donc ça c'est
la première naissance de l'anglicanisme
et ensuite la deuxième naissance c'est
Élisabeth 1ière c'est sa fille qui elle
pour le coup une fois passé le la
rupture avec Rome va accroître les
différences en fait et donc se
rapprocher un petit peu plus des
protestants même si dans la forme on
voit qu'il y a quand même pas mal
d'éléments qui se rapproche d'un culte
catholique et effectivement le la
rupture initiale c'est quand même le
fait que ce soit le le roi d'Angleterre
qui est à la tête de cette de cette
confessionab schmi toujours prenant
c'est ses débuts avec ses ses champ là
alors qu'on voit le prince William avec
sa femme son fils le Prince George et
puis et puis également le le roi
ici émouvant de voir toute une famille
et tout un un monde entier réuni pour
prier pour pour Elisabeth I cette
souveraine on prie pour la femme on prie
pour la souveraine et c'est d'autant
plus émouvant d'imaginer que sur ces
main marche elle elle avait reçu cette
cette couronne royale ce septe cette cap
si lourde qu'elle avait demandé l'aide
de l'archevêque de Westminster pour se
relever parce qu'elle n'y arrivait pas
et ce ce pouvait être aussi une
métaphore de cette lourde charge qui
l'attendait et qui n'a pas été simple à
à mener à travers toutes ces années les
charges dont elle s'est acquitté avec
une dignité et un sens du devoir que
tout le monde euh sal liue aujourd'hui
je crois Catherine FKI on va suivre
attentivement les images là
tout au long de cette cette messe les
personnes qui seront filmées là vous
voyez notamment le prince Harry est-ce
qu'on va filmer l'istrus la nouvelle
Première ministre est-ce qu'on va filmer
Joe Biden Emmanuel Macron tout ça est
très calculé j'imagine aussi je pense
que c'est très calculé et je pense que
la peine de souligner fait que elle
continue dans dans la mort à faire ce
qu'elle a fait dans la vie c'est-à-dire
à rassembler cette famille c'est
important de voir Charles et Camilla
c'est important de voir Méan et Harry
c'est important de voir le nouveau
prince de Gall et sa femme qui vont
jouer un rôle très important dans les
années qui viennent puisque Charles va
finalement être un pont entre la
monarchie de sa mère et et et et celle
de son fils donc le fait de pouvoir
rassembler dans la mort aussi bien que
dans la vie je crois que c'est c'est à
noter et effectivement rassembler les
dirigeants avec certaines certaines
exceptions évidemment et on sait que les
invités tion ont été finement calculé
pour à la
fois rassembler encore une fois les les
les importants de de ce monde sans
exclure ce dont on a besoin par exemple
l'Arabie Saoudite on écoute et on
retourne en direct à l'ABE de
Westminster Christ est
ressuscité
précédant ainsi ceux qui sont
morts en effet si la mort est venue à
travers un homme c'est aussi à travers
l'homme est venue la résurrection des
morts et comme tous MEUR en
Adam de même
aussi tous revivront en
Christ mais chacun a son propre
rang Christ en
premier puis ceux qui appartiennent à
Christ lors de son retour
ensuite viendra la
fin quand il le royaume à celui qui est
Dieu et
père après avoir anéanti toute
domination toute autorité et toute
puissance car il faut qu'il règne
jusqu'à ce qu'il a mis tous ses ennemis
sous ses
pieds le dernier ennemi qui sera
anéanti c'est la
mort
il faut que ce corps corruptible revête
l'incorruptibilité et que ce corps
mortel
revête
l'immortalité lorsque ce corps
corruptible aura revêtu
l'incorruptibilité et que ce corps
mortel aura revêtu
l'immortalité
alors
s'accomplira cette parole de
l'écriture la la mort a été engloutie
dans la
victoire O est ton
aiguillon ENF où est ta
victoire de la mort c'est le
péché et ce qui donne sa puissance au
péché c'est la
loi mais que Dieu soit remercé lui qui
nous donne la victoire par notre
Seigneur
Jésus-Christ ainsi mes frères et sœurs
Bienaimé soyez
ferme inébranlable
travailler de mieux en mieux à l'œuvre
du
Seigneur sachant que votre travail n'est
pas sans résultat dans le
Seigneur remercions le
Seigneur secrire général du commonweals
la baronne d'Écosse Patricia Scotland
c'est important Hélène de lozin là
d'unir le Commonwealth ce seront
peut-être les personnes qui seront au
premier rang c'est ça la priorité du roi
Charles I et dans les semaines qui
viennent que ce Commonwealth reste très
uni oui effectivement je pense que les
prochaines semaines pour le roi Charles
vont être particulièrement intenses en
terme de voyage diplomatique cette
semaine il a déjà consolidé les
différentes parties du royaume en allant
en Irlande du Nord au pays de gale et en
Écosse maintenant c'est effectivement la
page du Commonwealth qui s'ouvre je
pense qu'il ne faut pas surestimer les
envies de départ qu' peut y avoir de la
part des différents États-membres mais
il y a quand même certains maillons
faibles et on a pu le voir dans les
précédents mois notamment au moment de
la tournée effectuée par William et Kate
et cela va être un des objectifs de
Charles de maintenir tout ce beau monde
en en bonne entente en bonne
intelligence parce que la rumeur voulait
que ce Commonwealth tenait à cause
d'éliisabeth donc maintenant il va
falloir prouver qu'il tient au-delà
évidemment de
de la mort de de la reine parce qu' ils
vont avoir un rôle les les princes eux
aussi ils vont avoir un rôle parce que
le prince Charles on le sait veut un peu
réduire la la voilure en tout ce qui est
dans dans le rôle roi Charles voilà vous
voyez je suis je me suis toujours pas
faite en 10 jours c'est dire le roi
Charles donc veut réduire la voilure ve
que veut que il y a vraiment un cercle
resserré familial autour de lui ce qui
me frappe c'est que on on a parlé de
rassembler sans exclure on parle de
cette nécessité d'unifier le commonwes
mais il y a comme une mise en abîme
c'est comme si le roi Charles devait
faire la même chose avec sa famille
avoir vraiment des membres très
volontairees très très présents dans
leur rôle de membr qui travaillent au
sein de la famille royale et afficher
cette unité on le voit là il y a Méan et
Harry qui sont qui sont retirés de la
famille royale suite au mexite sont là
il y a il y a une double un double défi
pour le roi réaliser cette unité avec le
commonwes mais aussi au sein de sa
famille Catrine F qui le le Commonwealth
il faut à tout prix le
préserver je crois que du point de vue
de la couronne oui du point de vue du
Commonwealth comme comme on le disait
plutôt il y a des maillons faibles le
Canada où 51 % des Canadiens disent que
ils respectent effectivement la couronne
mais qui ne voit pas en quoi il devrait
y être rattaché et avoir le roi pour
pour chef d'État la Australie
aussé est pas forcément le nouveau
Premier ministre est pas
forcément grand fervant de la royauté
britannique non pas du tout alors ce qui
est intéressant c'est de savoir avec
quelle rapidité euh les il peut y avoir
des des mouvements là-dessus moi je ne
pense pas que ce sera dans les dans les
10 ou 15 années qui qui viennent je
crois que la question se posera plus
tard mais je pense quand même que que
pour le roi Charles c'est un c'est un
véritable défi et puis c'est reprendre
vraiment l'un des grands flambaux de sa
mère retournons à l'AB de Westminster
pour écouter très beau cœur pour cette
cérémonie que votre cœur ne se trouble
pas croyez en Dieu croyez aussi en
moi il y a beaucoup de demeur dans la
maison de mon père si ce n'était pas le
cas je vous l'Auris dit
je vais vous préparer une place et
puisque je vais vous préparer une
place je reviendrai et je vous prendrai
avec moi afin que là où je
suis vous y soyez
aussi vous savez où je vais et vous en
savez le
chemin thomas lui dit
seigneur nous ne savons pas où tu
vas comment pouvis-nous pouvons-nous en
savoir le
chemin Jésus lui dit c'est moi qui suis
le chemin la vérité et la
vie on ne vient au Père qu'en passant
par
moi si vous me connaissiez vous
connaîtriez aussi mon
père et dès maintenant vous le
connaissez et vous l'avez
vu Philippe lui dit Seigneur montre-nous
le père et cela nous
suffit Jésus lui dit il y a si longtemps
que je suis avec vous et tu ne me
connais pas
Philippe celui qui m'a vu a vu le
Père remercions le
Seigneur
Elisabeth dit l trust la toute nouvelle
Premier ministre du Royaume-Uni c'est
une rupture avec la franceab on Nimagine
pas un premier ministre français ou un
président de la République faire une
lecture à la messe et non et c'est là
qu'on voit que la monarchie britannique
n'est pas seulement quelque chose
d'esthétique et de de propre à flatter
nos goûts pour les compes de fé mais
c'est une une institution politique
réelle et qui compte certainement dans
le dans la vie politique il est on a
beaucoup blosé sur les les liens entre
la reine et ses Premier ministre et ses
fameux entretiens du mercredi qui ne
fuitait pas dont on ne sait presque rien
on sait tout de même que margarette
tcher par exemple lui rendait hommage
rendait hommage à la reine avec qui elle
avait eu sans doute des différents mais
en disant que c'était la femme du monde
la plus renseignée la mieux informé
Harold al je je vous dis aussi ce que
disait margarette tchard parce que c'est
un papier ce matin qui est dans le
journal elle disait aussi le problème
est que la reine est le genre de femme
qui pourrait voter socialdémocrate voilà
donc on a des hommages et pas que de
dans dans le Figaro consacrant à la
reine il y a un article de Jean-Louis
tiriot qui s'appelle au-dessus de la
mêlée et qui est sur ce thème du rôle
politique de la reine quelle influence
avait-elle on pourrait dire mais en fait
elle vous savez elle ne gouverne pas
elle règne mais ne gouverne pas certes
mais elle avait certainement une
influence en tout cas morale sur sur son
premier ministre qu'elle voyait je vous
citerai les mots de Harold Wilson qui
fut premier ministre travailliste aimait
beaucoup qu'elle aimait beaucoup et
qu'elle s'entendait bien et qui le lui
rendait bien en disant que finalement la
reine était la seule personne qui lui
parlait dont il savait que leur
conversation ne fuiterait pas et qu'elle
ne voulait pas lui voler sa place et
donc il de son propre aveu il écoutait
les avis de la reine et euh pour
reprendre la formule du professeur
frédéric Rouvillois ellisabeth était un
modèle discret mais convaincant de
conservatisme spontané par ce qu'elle
était par sa présence sans doute par ses
conseils et et donc la le fait que le
premier ministre lise la la deuxème
lecture à lors des funérailles de
laarine nous semble bien incongru nous
Français mais à tout son sens dans un un
système monarchique où sans doute le
rôle du monarque compte kaatherine faski
Distr elle est déjà
entré dans l'histoire elle est déjà
entrée dans l'histoire puisque ça a été
le finalement le dernier acte officiel
de la reine que de la que de la recevoir
et elle est rentrée dans l'histoire et
tout le monde retient un petit peu sa
respiration parce que à partir de demain
matin les affaires courantes reprennent
et ce ne sont pas des affaires courantes
faciles euh c'est elle s'inscrit dans un
moment compliqué sa désignation son
élection par les membres du Parti
conservateur a dominé en fait tout tout
l'été politique au Royaume-Uni et euh
demain commence un
risque d'être d'être compliqué les cœurs
de l'AB de Westminster on
[Musique]
écoute venez Esprit
Saint remplissez notre cœur avec le Baum
de ton
amour
AMEN
le pur pour bien des
dirigeant c'est
d'être célébré en vie et oublié dans la
mort le patne pour ceux qui servent
Dieu qui soit respecté ou
ignorer et que la mort soit la porte
pour la
gloire Sa Majesté a
déclaré à l'anniversaire de ses 21 ans
que toute sa vie sera dédiée au service
de la nation et du
comm il est très rare qu'une promesse a
été aussi bien
tenue
pe de dirigeants reçoivent tout l'amour
que nous avons
vu Jésus dans S
écritures ne dit pas à ses disciples
comment suivre mais qui
suivre il dit je suis le
chemin la vérité et la
vie maesté
exemple non pas à travers sa position ni
son
ambition mais à travers qui elle
suivait je sais que Sa Majesté partage
sa foi et son espoir en Jésus-Christ
comme sa mère avant
lui le même sens du
devoir en
1953 la reine démarra son couronnement
avec une prière silencieuse ici à
l'hôtel son serment envers Dieu a été
donné avant que toute personne ne donne
son allégeance à
elle son service auprès de tous les
peuples de cette nation et du
Commonwealth du monde
entier prenne naissance dans sa foi
Dieu lui-même dit qu'il n'était pas venu
pour être servi mais pour
servir pour donner sa vie à
tous RAR sont ceux qui se dévouent
manière RAR sont les dirigeants qui se
dévouent de la
sorte tous les cas ceux qui servent
seront
aimés alors que ceux qui s'accrochent au
pouvoir et au privilège seront
oubliés le deuil d'aujourd'hui non
seulement ressenti par la famille de la
reine mais par tous à travers le monde
vient de sa vie
d'abondance et de service qui maintenant
et plus
elle était joyeuse présente elle a
touché tellement de
vie et nous prions aujourd'hui
particulièrement pour toute sa famille
qui pleure comme toute famille lors d'un
enterrement et compris bien des familles
autour du monde qui eux-mêmes ont perdu
quelqu'un
récemment dans le cas de cette famille
ce deuil se fait à la vue de
tous que Dieu guérisse leur
peine et que leur vie soit marquée par
des souvenirs de
joie la diffusion de Sa Majesté la
Reine pendant le
confinement se terminit avec les phrases
nous nous reverrons des mots
d'espoir
chrétien avec l'attente de quelque chose
qu'on ne voit pas encore le Christ a
ressuscité et a offert la vie à tous une
vie
abondante
aujourd'hui une vie abondante avec Dieu
dans l'éternité comme le dit le champ de
Noël quand les esprits souvr
chist nous ferons tous face au jugement
de
Dieu nous pouvons tous partager l'Espoir
de la
Reine
d'inspirer ce
serviteur le service durant sa
vieoir dans la
mort exemple et son inspiration dans la
foi pourrons avec elle
dire nous nous
reverrons les mots de l'archevêque de
canterberry pas qu'Al une pe intéressant
ce qu'il dit une famille qui ne peut pas
faire son deuil autrement qu'en public
une famille de toute façon qui n'a pas
vécu sa vie autrement qu'en public quel
que soit leur statut les membres à plus
forte raison S sont très exposés mais
les membres de la FIE royale dès qu'ils
naissent leur enfance leur adolescence
tout est fait de tout tout est fait tout
se vit devant les caméras là ce qui est
intéressant quand même c'est qu'on on
sent quand même une une humanisation on
a vu dans la procession tout à l'heure
le prince Andreou notamment qui est l'un
des parias de la famille suite à ses son
implication dans le scandale
stin visiblement ému on voit le le roi
Charles très grave euh les princes
William et Harry eux aussi ont l'air
très émus
il y a
cette cette véritable affliction qui
affleur comme ça du côté des hommes
contrebalancé par la grande dignité des
femmes qui aussi qui qui qui fait un peu
oublier aussi le fameux conflit megéan
Markel et Kate Middleton là tout le
monde est sur le même la même longueur
d'onde donc voilà il y a une véritable
humanisation pardon dans son deuil à la
vue de tous et je pense que là aussi ça
nempêche pas qu'elle est sincère mais ça
participe à cette opération de
communication qui est quand même ce qui
sont quand même ces fun l'INE de lein
lorsqu'on est reine roi on s'appartient
plus s'appartient plus vraiment c'est la
règle c'est la règle du jeu même si
effectivement il y a eu au fil des
siècles des des aménagements progressifs
on a eu la même chose sur la monarchie
française à partir du 18e siècle et
c'est un des grands drames de
Marie-Antoinette par exemple c'est
d'avoir envie d'avoir une sorte de de
vie privée alors que rien n'est fait
pour justement accorder cette petite
place à l'intimité dans la dans la
monarchie et je pense que évidemment il
y a des évolutions et Pascaline
soulignait l'humanis qui transparaî de
manière discrète dans cette cérémonie
néanmoins je pense que l'une des forces
d'Élisabeth i c'est d'avoir aussi tenu
la barre de cette représentation de
cette de cette impassibilité ce qui la
rend je dirais peut-être pas
suprahumaine mais particulièrement
puissante dans son autorité c'est que
pour le coup elle n'a quasiment jamais
rien cédé 34 nous sommes en direct nous
suivons depuis laab de Westminster la
cérémonie d'adieu à la reine ellisabeth
I
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ish
N
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi
ch
[Musique]
V
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prion notre
père rendons grâce à Dieu pour la longue
vie et le long règne de la reine
Élisabeth soyons reconnaissant pour sa
sagesse
et son
service oh Dieu source de tout ce qui
est droit et
vrai accepte nos remerciements pour les
dons de cœur et d'esprit que tu as donné
à ta fille
Élisabeth et qu'elle nous a
montré en parole
et en
Act
accorde-nous de vivre notre vie selon ta
volonté de chercher le bien de
tous et de rest fidèles serviteurs toute
notre
vie à travers notre Seigneur
Jésus-Christ
AMEN
confiant en l'amour et la compassion de
Dieu prion pour tous ceux dont le cœur
est alourdi par la peine du
[Musique]
deuil Dieu
tout-puissant père de toute miséricorde
toi qui nous
réconfores nous te prions d'être
gracieux
qui
pleur et qu'en se remettant à
toi il connaiss la consolation de ton
amour à travers JésusChrist notre
Seigneur
amen prions pour sa majesté le RO et
toute la famille
royale qu'
connaiss t
pouvoir et l'amitié de ton
peuple Dieu tout-puissant source de tout
ce qui est bon nous te demandons
humblement de bénir notre gracieux roi
Charles Camilla la reine
consort William le prince de Gal et
toute la famille
royal que le Saint-Esprit leur
Vienne que ta grâce divine abonde en eux
accorde-leur le
bonheur et conduis-les vers le royaume
éternel à travers notre Seigneur Jésus
amen en reconnaissance du dévouement que
la reine Élisabeth a eu pour le Royaume
Uni réjouissons-nous dans son dévouement
indéfectible pour son devoir pour en sa
compassion pour ses sujets
et son conseil auprès de ses
ministres nous prions pour la bonne
santé et la
prospérité de cette
nation Dieu tout-puissant don la volonté
de tes enfants te serv à travers les uns
les
autres nous te prions d'apporter ta
bonté à cette
nation acce àes citoyens la grâce de TR
emble de manière honnête et fidèle avec
le souci de vrer pour le bien de tous en
cherchant la justice de ton royaume il
trouvve tout ce dont ils ont besoin
chaque
jour pour le bien
commun à travers Jésus-Christ notre
Seigneur
amen grce à la son engagementv le comm à
travers son
règne pour le dévouement qu'elle a
montré à ses
peuples et les liens riches de
fraternité et d'entraide qu'elle a su
entretenir Dieu éternel toutpuissant
entend notre prière pour le
Common et accordei l'appui de ta
sagesse qui en position d'autorité à
promouvoir la justice et le bien
commun donne à tous ces citoyens
l'esprit de l'honneur et du respect
mutuel et accorde-nous tous la grâce
der pour que la justice et la paix soi
faite pour l'honneur de ton nom
AMEN
intéressant Hélène de Lain là de voir
toutes les églises qui se succèdent et
qui prennent la parole quiz- mooi
effectivement donc là on vient de voir
toute une série de dignitaires religieux
parce qu'évidemment l'anglicanisme c'est
la la religion je DIRIS pas la religion
officielle il y a pas de religion au
sens religion d'État mais là on a toutes
les autres communautés protestantes qui
ont chacune pris leur pris la parole
donc l'Église d'Écosse les églises
indépendantes on a eu l'archevêque de
Londres là à l'instant l'archevêque de
Westminster donc chacun évidemment il y
a pas de séparation stricte de de
l'Église et de l'État chacun rend
hommage à la reine et chacun se sent
finalement membre d'une même fraternité
chrétienne quel que soient les
dénominations qui la religion est
politique la religion est est politique
à partir du moment où le chef d'État est
aussi le chef de l'église de l'église
anglicane mais mais je crois que cela va
être un des un des défis de Charles dans
les années qui viennent c'est de
reconnaître les autres communautés
religieuses qui sont plus minoritaire au
Royaume-Uni et de leur faire une place
dans dans cette dans cette fraternité je
crois que c'est quelque chose auquel il
va s'atteler et qui risque de de créer
quelques petites difficultés c'est un
véritaable défi mais on s'y attend
pourquoi des difficulté parce que je
pense que il y a une il y a les les
communautés religieuses qui ont été
présent à l'instant sont sont celles qui
sont le plus communément reconnu et
accepté et je crois que le le roi
Charles a une fibre multiculturelle et
multiculturaliste beaucoup plus prononcé
et et chacun se demande comment comment
il va vivre ce
multiculturalisme au niveau religieux
dans les années qui viennent vous me
dites par exemple c'est que là toutes
les tendances du christianisme sont
représenté pas l'islam pas toutes il y a
pas les catholiques par exemple donc là
ce sont uniquement des al voir un
cardinal non ah oui mais c'est un un
cardinal protestant vous avez pas de euh
vous avez pas de ah pardon non c'était
oui non c'était l'archevêque de
Westminster ouis euh vous avez pas ici
de euh comment dire de vous êtes dans le
monde enfin toutes les dénominations qui
sont proches de l'angicanisme et du
protestantisme mais vous av pas
d'orthodoxes qui ont pris la parole vous
avez pas de je sais pas de Syriac que
sais-je si je peux me permettre
l'homélie de l'archevêque euh qui qui a
pris de de cabur qui a prêché disait ce
que l'on célèbre à travers ellisabeth
c'est ce qu'elle a été également celui
qu'elle a suivi ce qui montre que en
réalité la la foi du souverain n'est pas
faite pour incarner toutes les fois
religieuses de tous ces sujet parce que
là effectivement il y a un un patchwork
multiculturaliste fait que il devrait
changer de religion tous les 3 jours si
s'il voulait incarner toutes les
religions représentées dans son royaume
mais c'est la foi à laquelle adhère la
fois au dieu auquel il croit et et et
pour lequel il est investi de la mission
d'être roi donc je pense que c'est
important de resituer les choses dans
cette perspective que c'est une
monarchie de droit divin et que à ce
titre sont en plus de chef de l'Église
ajoute aussi au fait que il s'agit d'une
foi chrétienne et et pas de la
représentation de toutes les fois
religieuses de son royaume ou on sait
par exemple Catherine que Boris Johnson
était le premier Premier ministre
catholique donc même au sein de du
gouvernement et bien évidemment il y a
différentes tendances bien sûr et et et
ces tendances et et la diversité de ces
tendances c'est un petit peu ce qui fait
la richesse du du du du Royaume-Uni ce
qui est intéressant c'est que Charles
voit les
choses de façon plus inclusive peut-être
que que d'autres et donc c'est pour ça
que je je soulignais je soulignais ce
défi on retourne à l' Westminster pas
seulement en image on écoute ce qu'il
s'y passe
également volonté soit faite sur la
terre comme au ciel donne-nous
aujourd'hui notre pain de ce
jour pardonne-nous nos offenses comme
nous pardonnons aussi à ceux qui nous
ont
offensé et ne nous soumets pas à la
tentation mais délivre-nous du
mal à toi sont le royaume la puissance
et la gloire pour des siècles et des
siècles Amen
[Musique]
for
my
[Musique]
C
š
sē
zā
[Musique]
asī
sī
zemusī
II
[Musique]
sā
L
[Musique]
as
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de retour ici en plateau figure on reste
avec les images à l'abille de de
Westminster oui je je corrige parce que
PASC sur Figaro.fr le cardinal Nichols
est un cardinal catholique évidemment
jéréy St nous a rejoint merci d'être ici
bonjour que pense et que ressent le
Britannique que vous êtes aujourd'hui
est-ce que c'est l'équivalent je sais
pas en France peut-être de grande dates
comme la libération de Paris ou autres
est-ce que ce sera un moment marquant de
l'histoire de votre pays oui c'est une
grande date je ne parlerai pas de la
libération de Paris parce
que c'est quand même différent ici c'est
de la pure cérémonie h mais de la plus
haute importance est-ce que on se
souviendra dans les livres d'histoire 19
septembre 2022 est-ce que ce sera
étudier je je le pense je le pense parce
que même si on remonte dans le
passé aucune cérémonie royale même
atteint ses
proportions regardé par tellement de
gens à travers le monde et en
suscitant une telle émotion populaire je
ne crois pas que la mort de Henri VII
par exemple et suscitait une grande
émotion populaire de la même manière
même pas pour ellizabeth prière donc
c'est la reine Victoria par exemple
peut-être on est dans ces eau là mais je
dirais que là grâce bien sûr aux médias
dans nous euh c'est c'est décuplé c'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'unique
est-ce que aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a
une pe de la famille royale va analyser
les chiffres d'audience est-ce que on
est là-dedans pour voir quelle est sa
popularité à quel point elle est encore
influente importante oui je pense que
oui parce que c'est une famille royale
qui vit avec son temps qui vit avec les
réseaux sociaux ils sont très présents
sur Instagram notamment il disentil des
photos de manière très très calculée des
je pense que là il ne poent évidemment
pas maintenant mais c'est pas sans doute
pas eux mais leurs services de
communication mais qu'ensuite on va
avoir l'image qui va bien et ça dépasse
même juste l'émotion et la la la
révérence faite à la reine va y avoir
tout le monde va commenter demain la
façon dont Megan Markel et Kat Mton
étaient habillé la façon dont les
enfants sont habillés on a les images
très touchantes là de des enfants qui
commencent un peu à trouver peut-être le
temps long à à passer sur le le livre de
M les pages du livre de MESS mais oui
c'est une famille qui vit avec son temps
qui sait exactement à quel point son
image est capitale aujourd'hui dans la
façon dont le dont les dont la
population britannique la respecte et
elle doit vraiment faire attention à ça
pour cette ce nouveau chapitre qui s
elle Hélène de lazin dans cette abaye de
Westminster il y a notamment Joe Biden
et notamment Emmanuel Macron on les a
pas encore vu à l'image depuis le début
de de cette cérémonie non vous avez tout
à fait raison il n'y a pas de zoom sur
les les autres people du jour et je
trouve que c'est assez révélateur
finalement ils sont secondaires dans ce
dans ce cérémonial on notrea qu'on a pas
vu effectivement ni Biden ni Macron mais
on n' pas vu non plus les autres peê
couronnés qui sont présentes ou donc il
pas présidents il a quand même d'autres
représentants de famille royale
européenne mais ça n'est pas la que
d'ailleurs on peut on peut le dire
l'empereur narito du Japon premier
voyage à l'étranger depuis son accession
au Trô en 2019 le roi d'Espagne féipe 6
également son père Juan Carlos qui est
en exil aux Émirats arabes unis qui est
également présent le Prince Albert de de
Monaco la reine la seule reine encore
régante en en Europe Margret du du
Danemark ils sont tous présents et c'est
vrai qu'on a vu des images que de de la
la famille royale Jér St c'est important
cette unité de la famille royale oui euh
pour vu qu'elle dure et c'est la
question que tout le monde se pose parce
que là c'est un un grand moment
d'émotion de
réconciliation euh mais après qu'est-ce
qui va se passer souvent c'est comme les
amours de vacances après la fin ouis du
temps joyeux on on retourne à aux choses
normales
on a quand même un nouveau roi alors
peut-être que sa présence va continuer à
rapprocher les membres de la famille
mais on ne sait pas ce qu'il se sont
dit pendant ces jours de communion en
quelque sorte on verra on verra d'ici le
weekend prochain beaucoup de choses
probablementi 54 nous sommes toujours en
direct pour cette messe à l'ABE de
Westminster en hommage à la reine
ellisabeth 2 pour pour ces funérailles
qui devrait être suivi aujourd'hui par
plus de 4 milliards de personnes mais ce
qui touche à sa fin et on suit ça en
direct on écoute on
[Musique]
regarde
que Dieu accorde grâce aux
vivants repos au
défuns paix et harmonie à l'église au
roi au Commonwealth et au
peuple et à nous pauvres pécheurs la vie
éternelle et la bénédiction de Dieu
tout-puissant le Père le Fils et le
Saint-Esprit soit avec vous pour
toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
is
as
[Applaudissements]
ses
Onas
Sonu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aon entendu god save the Queen ou god
save the king telle est la question sur
ce plateau évidemment ch mubs une
émotion forcément et c'est peut-être
l'une des dernières fois que l'on entend
probablement nous qu sur ce plateau que
l'on entend god save the queen tout à
fait tout à fait c'est c'est vraiment
l'adieu parce que à la fin de la
cérémonie des funérailes
on dit adieu et bien ce n'est pas le
l'adieu définitif parce que ça reste
pour la chapelle à Winsor il y a déjà un
un adieu il y a maintenant une
lamentation
au cornemuse alors c'est le joueur de
cornomus personnel de la reine voilà je
vous propose qu'onout c'est la fin de la
[Musique]
fin
voilà pour
cette vous m'avez dit Jérémie c'est un
hommage à la cornemuse he c'est
ça la qui marque la fin la fin du du ici
les 13h Philippe Gell directeur adjoint
de la rédaction du Figaro nous a rejoint
bonjour Philippe moment marquant moment
important j'imagine que vous avez suivi
ça Mo important sur le plan
international également bien sûr il y a
énormément de dirigeants du monde qui
sont
venu pour cette circonstance absolument
exceptionnelle je suis quand même frappé
par le fait qu'on les a pratiquement pas
vu pratiquement
inexistant dans le protocole ça c'est
normal mais
tout tourne autour de la famille royale
britannique ce qui est
normal on a vu cette image au début de
Joe Biden et et Jill Biden entouré de
gens sûrement très éminents mais
absolument
inconnus personne n'était capable
d'identifier on les a vu arriver on les
a vu arver mais ils sont assis entourés
de de gens selon des règles probablement
protocolaire doivent être des des
dirigeants ce que vous me dites c'est
qu'on a mis Emmanuel Macron Joe Biden et
tous les autres au beau milieu de la
foule avec ce sont des figurant de cette
de cette cérémonie et c'est normal on
peut pas en être autrement tout
l'enjeu
presque presque géopolitique même si le
mot est un peu un peu un peu grand pour
pour la circonstance mais c'était d'en
être d'être là et
ensuite de ne pas forcément tirer à soi
ou ou même de ne pas du tout tirer à soi
la la les projecteurs il faut rester
dans l'anonymat d'une foule euh qui se
recueille au côté des Britanniques au
côté des des dirigeants britanniques
dans cette église et du peuple
britannique dans les rues on va avoir le
temps d' d'en parler parce que oui vous
avez raison après cette cérémonie à
l'abayie de Westminster et bien le
cercueil va prendre la direction des des
rues de Londres Jérémy j'imagine que les
Londoniens les Anglais les Britanniques
attendent aussi ce moment là c'est
vraiment la fin définitivement c'est
c'est le à chaque moment il y a le début
d'une nouvelle fin parce que maintenant
le le cercueil va être tirer jusqu'au à
l'arc de du duc de Wellington donc là il
y aura plein de monde ensuite ça partira
en voiture de Londres jusqu'à Winsor et
là le long de la route il y aura encore
des gens on arrive une trentaine de
kilomètres hein c'est ça à peu près
entre une trentaine de kilomètres à peu
près exactement pas plus et euh et en
arrivant à windnsor il y a dans le grand
parc il y a un très long chemin qui
s'appelle la longue marche et il y a
encore des gens là pour regarder passer
le cercueil 5 voilà c'est très grand 7
km je l'ai fait moi-même à pied c'est
très très long mais donc à chaque étape
il y aura du monde donc elle ne sera
vraiment
seule que que que ce soir quand elle ser
de son mari Hélène de lausin toujours du
du symbole in kit à paraître un peu
désué mais jusquau bout dans cette
cérémonie on fait pas preuve de
modernité on s'en moque presque le
symbole de bout en bout je dirais même
qu'on non seulement on s'en moque mais
ce serait sacrilège c'est vraiment je
pense que c'est ce qui fait aussi le
succès de ce type d'événement c'est que
on retrouve ce qu'on a envie de de voir
et et c'est ce qui incarne la continuité
parfaite vous voyez Charles I il choisit
son son nom il prend la suite de Charles
2 qui a vécu au 17e siècle et on fait un
bon de 400 ans grâce à cette continuité
et le cérémonial est là aussi pour pour
garantir cela le cercueil qui est à
nouveau mené vers cette ce canon hein
vous savez ce ce pont qui alors j'ai
j'ai retrouver le nom C affut de canon
le State gun funeral carriage de la
Royal Navy utilisé pour le transport des
cercueils de la reine Victoria du roi
Edward 7 du roi George 6 de Winston
churchield et de Lord mountbaton le
symbole jusqu'au bout c'est pas un moyen
de transport pour n'importe qui
apparemment le dire qu'on tourne les
roues de ce cet affu de canon d'un/4
tous les ans ou tous les 6 mois c'est ça
pour éviter qu'elle ne s'affaisse
d'accord et pour s'assurer qu'elle
éviter une distorsion dans les dans les
roues ex Philippe Gell on peut commencer
à parler peut-être de ce grand
rassemblement international vous l'avez
déjà évoqué un peu certains sont absents
Vladimir Poutine notamment d'autres sont
représentés je pense aux Chinois je
pense aux Turcs je pense au saoudiens
est-ce que on est là dans une
représentation de ce qui se fait en ce
moment sur la scène géopolitique
internationale il y a de monde oui bien
sûr c'est un reflet de l'état des
relations internationales il y a SEP
pays qui n'ont pas été
invités parce que ils n'ont pas
aujourd'hui de relation diplomatique
avec RoyaumeUni donc la Russie la
Biélorussie pour en raison de la guerre
en Ukraine mais aussi le
Venezuela le Nicaragua je
crois l'Afghanistan des Taliban et la
syri la Syrie éalement et la Syrie de
Bachar al-Assad la Corée même la Corée
du Nord ont été invités à envoyer un
ambassadeur les Chinois ont été invités
mais c'est sijin ping lui-même qui s'est
fait représenter par un vice Premier
ministre vice
vice-présidentésidés mais apparemment un
vieil ami à lui donc ce n'est pas c'est
quand même quelque chose de positif W
Kishan voilà vice-président c'est ça et
donc euh oui on a un reflet alors bon
parlons d'abord des Russes puisque
l'absence la plus visible évidemment
c'est celle de Vladimir Poutine on en
connaît tous les raisons ça ne fait
presque pas débat je ne pense pas que ça
ait fait débat dans l'organisation des
funérailles par par les autorités
britanniques mais il y a quand même une
petite humiliation pour
poure bien sûr parce que d'abord il y a
il y a des liens de sang entre les
dynasties russes c'est ça le Marie
d'Élisabeth est un descendant direct av
des origines greces et russes voilà est
un descendant direct de duutsar oui
absolument alors ça fait pas de Vladimir
Poutine le représentant d'sar bien sûr
et il faut il faut pas tout mélanger et
chacun chacun a un rôle différent lui il
est président de la Russie d'aujourd'hui
qui est un pays en guerre qui a envahi
un voisin et cetera mais
euh il est probable d'ailleurs que s'il
avait été invité il ne serait pas venu
je je oui alors c'est ça ils ont annoncé
il a dit d'ailleurs il a dit de toute
façon je ne serais pas venu oui mais il
l' dit il l'a dit comme on
dit on vous donne pas on vous donne pas
quelque chose que vous souhaitez et puis
alors on dit de toute façon j' j'en
aurais pas voulu bon difficile de savoir
en tout cas les Britanniques ont
clairement d'emblé fait savoir qu'il
n'inviterait pas il a le le il aurait pu
se taire il aurait pu ne rien s'abstenir
de réagir en disant pour moi c'est un
une un non événement ou une nonination
que que de ne pas y aller ils ont marqué
leur vexation les Russes finalement je
pense qu'il a marqué une petite vexation
en disant de toute façon je n'y serai
pas allé la la porte il me semble la
porte-parole des Affaires étrangères a
pris la parole en expliquant que c'était
honteux de de profiter de du contexte de
la blasfématoire exactement le terme
était très fort de profiter de la
situation de la guerre en Ukraine pour
justement régler des comptes bon est-ce
qu'il aurait était très sage sur le plan
même sécuritaire pour Vladimir Poutine
de de s'aventurer en Europe de l'Ouest
c'est pas sûr donc on peut fermer ce
chapitre là après euh il y a
effectivement ceux qui sont t présents
même si on les voit très peu durant la
cérémonie il y a le niveau de représ de
représentation de de chaque État qui
donne une petite indication de ce qu'on
veut montrer ou
pas il a il y a pas mal de présidents
qui sont un peu qui veulent garder une
neutralité par exemple sur la guerre en
Ukraine qui se sont fait représenter par
un premier ministre nous suivons les la
sortie à palan du cortège et du cercueil
des abeth 2 de cette abeli de
Westminster qui sera à nouveau posée sur
cette affu canon affu canon tiré par 142
marins et qui traversera Londres dans
quelques instants on s'imprègne à
nouveau de l'ambiance et de ce qu' se
passe à la baille de
Westminster
[Musique]
vent le cercueil de la reen Elisabeth I
qui sort de l'abaye de Westminster pour
entamer sa procession dans dans Londres
Philippe c'est toujours ça me paraît
étonnant en miroir de du pouvoir réel
qu' avait la reine d'Angleterre qui
maintenant le roi
d'Angleterre la puissance qui est
classée par rapport à il y a 200 ans de
Royaume-Uni la puissance que dégage
aujourd'hui l'Angleterre et toutit il y
a quelque chose de très très frappant à
voir tous ces dignitaires étrangers en
partie mais s'incliner devant le
cercueil de la reine qui passe devant
eux on a l'impression qu'on enterre une
sorte de reine mondiale euh comme si
elle était la reine de nous n'avons pas
de droit mais si nous en avions si nous
avions une monarchie ben on pourrait se
presque se se référer à celle-ci on
n'imagine pas d'autres souverains régant
actuellement euh dans le
monde qui pourrai avoir des funérailles
de équivalentes c'est c'est
inimaginable les les les souverains
d'Espagne de Norvège du de Belgique sont
très estimables mais pas une seconde on
ne pourrait imaginer que le monde entier
se retrouve à un tel niveau pour leur
funéraill et on le on leur souhaite pas
ce ce triste sort bien sûr mais bon la
reine a bien sûr régné 70 ans ce qui
explique aussi son son son accession au
rang de d'icône internationale Jérémy
est-ce que justement les Britanniques se
raccrochent à ça est-ce que c'est un
symbole de puissance qu'on ne veut
surtout pas
lâcher c'est très paradoxal parce que on
dirait des funérailles impérial impérial
mais en fait le Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui
c'est diff quelle différence et nuance
vous faites entre impérial et
royale justement c'est cette idée que là
c'est le la monarque non seulement d'un
un pays comme l'Espagne ou le Danemark
mais beaucoup plus comme s'il y avait
toujours un empire sauf qu'il y en a pas
il n'y a surtout pas
et il y a quand même 16 royaumes au
total ce qui n'est pas rien il en il en
reste certain mais on sait que ce n'est
pas un empire on ne dicte pas à ces à
ces pays le leur
politique et on sait qu'il y en a qui
veulent se se libérer de la euh du
monarque britannique comme chef d'État
mais il y a d'un côté une grande
nostalgie peut-être h h il y a aussi
quand même l'idée que bon c'est un un un
peu ridicule mais on on parle sans doute
on a les myes équivalent en français on
appelait la la la PAX Britannica la paix
britannique qu'avait apporté le le
Royaume-Uni S quelque chose de l'Empire
et que ce soit complètement fantaisiste
ou non il y a cette idée d'une sorte de
paix universelle qui apporte je pense
que c'est la même chose en France
qu'apporte la démocratie moderne et s
incarné curieusement par des cérémonies
royales Hélène vous êtes historienne
est-ce qu'on peut mesurer l'échelle de
l'histoire l'important c'est le pouvoir
aujourd'hui de la monarchie britannique
par rapport à d'autres époques alors
effectivement il n'y a plus d'empire
comme le disait Jérémie à l'instant
néanmoins il y a une forme d'Empire dans
le sens où il y a la la reconnaissance
d'une voilà d'un lien qui unit des des
des états des pays et qui qui ont le
sentiment d'avoir un destin commun euh
je sais pas si vous avez suivi cette cet
épisode apparemment anecdotique mais
deux pays d'Afrique francophones
récemment on choisit de rejoindre le
Commonwealth alors qu'il n'était
traditionnellement pas des d'anciennes
colonies britanniques c'est le Gabon et
le Togo et euh et c'est vrai que c'est
un signe intéressant parce que ce n'est
pas du tout dans leur passé ils ne sont
pas d'ancienne colonie britannique mais
ils reconnaissent qu'il y a justement un
lien extrêmement fort qui perdure à
travers les âges et qui a toujours du
sens aujourd'hui pH parallèlement ça ça
tiraille pas mal au sein du comm World
notamment l'Australie par exemple oui
l'Australie le Canada quand vous faites
des sondages dans ces pays-là vous avez
une majorité plus ou moins grande mais
en général une majorité qui pencherait
pour la République alors c'est c'est un
petit peu indécent d'en parler
maintenant et et toutes ces
revendications ont été ont été
tu et apaisé TR a tout de suite dit non
non on nouvre pas le débat Anthony
albanisé en Australie qui lui est pro
République a dit on en parle pas pour
l'instant et ça tout ça va va va échoir
au roi au roi Charles bien sûr et il a
adopté d'emblé une position très je
dirais cool là-dessus très ouverte et
bien il a dit il y a toutes sortes de
façons de
s'arranger quand on on veut
modifier les relations que l'entretient
c'est un des gros avantages du
Commonwealth qui dès l'origine s'est
posé comme un système très souple et les
modalités d'association sont je ne
dirais pas qu'il y en a une par état
mais presque c'est il y a quand même une
plasticité de l'organisme qui qui
facilite ça il faut distinguer parce que
pour être membre du Commonwealth on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir le monarque
britannique comme chef d'État d'accord
ça c'est 56 alors qu'il n'y a que 16
cour voilà tout à fait tout à fait et
donc il est vrai que on sait déjà que au
moins six pays des Caraïbes ont annoncé
leur intention de se débarrasser en
quelque sorte de la monarchie et ça va
probablement se passer comme ça mais on
a déjà vu avec la Barbade qui qui qui a
ouvert le bal l'année dernière et et et
et et là leur dirigeants politique ont
gardé très bonne relation avec le
Royaume-Uni pas qu'on plaque la porte et
que tout est fini entre nous ex et le
grand enjeu qui domine tous les autres
c'est évidemment celui de l'Écosse où là
il y a un paradoxe parce que les
Écossais pourraient être tentés par
l'indépendance mais il pourrait garder
la couronne Philippe c'est-à-dire faire
de de de Charles I leur roi tout en
étant plus dans le Royaume-Uni ça
m'intéresse je veux qu'on parle de
l'Écosse justement on retourne un peu
dans les rues de Londres parce que ça y
est le cercueil sur cette affu canon a
démarré sa procession dans Londres
jusqu'à l'arche rappelez-moi PhIP
l'arche le son nom quel est le nom de de
cet arge jusqu'où on va ce qu'on voit là
la fin de la procession l'ARGE
deingonàington ça c'est plus loin on
pasci on dit dans
l'oreillette de Wellington c'est et bien
on écoute on suit ce qui se passe dans
les r de Londres et on revient ici en
[Musique]
plateau
Hélène c'est la la partie populaire de
cette de ces funérailles qui vient de
débuter toujours il faut être vu c'est
ça être vu pour être cru jusqu'au bout
même le cercueil ah ben déjà il faut
penser à tous ceux qui ont fait la queue
et qui n'ont pas pu aller rendre hommage
à Westminster h puisquil y a un moment
où il a a fallu bien arrêter la la la
queue donc ça donne d'autant plus de
raison et puis effectivement comme le
soulignait Jérémie ça n'en finit pas de
finir donc on peut être là jusqu'au bout
Jérémy moment historique on en parlait
là le le peuple britannique et dans la
rue ça peut nous étonner nous Français
oui oui bien sûr mais en fait je pense
que ça étonne les Britanniques aussi ah
bon ah oui tout à fait tout à fait ça
n'arrive pas tous les jours ce n'est pas
programmé la cérémonie est programmée
sans doute
mais le cerveau n'est pas nécessairement
programmé et c'est comparé avec les
funérailles de la princesse
Diana là aussi il y avait beaucoup de
monde mais les gens
pleurai cri il y avait beaucoup de de
spontanéité là c'est très mesuré mais en
quelque sorte plus profond quand même
c'est pas tout à fait pareil c'est une
femme qui avait 96 ans contre face à au
décès d'une la prinise du peuple he
c'est ça voilà mais la première mort
c'était une tragédie là c'est une fin
inévitable mais tout le monde se
projette dans cette fin
et comme on l'a déjà dit non seulement
toutes les branches des forces armées
sont représenté mais les différents
pays on va peut-être en parler de
l'Écosse de l'Irlande du Nord betgal
sont sont sont là il y a quelque chose
pour tout le monde il est pas avant
qu'on parle de l'Écosse euh ce qu'on a
ce qu'on voit juste derrière le le
cercueil la famille royale les trois
frères et sœurs côte à côte oui euh on
peut imaginer que le roi Charles aurait
pu euh se tenir seul euh euh premier
interpariss derrière le cercueil de sa
mère mais non parce que il est encore
dans le rôle d'un d'un fils et son frère
et sa sœur sont marche sur le même rang
je trouve que c'est un message de
certaine humilité peut-être n venons de
VO et comme vous le disiez ce qui est
très frappant effectivement Diana
c'était une tragédie là c'est un moment
historique avec tout ce que ça comporte
de solenité d'émotion et peut-être un
peu de gravité mais les gens assistent à
un passage
euh on tourne une page de 70 années donc
très très longue 90 % des des
Britanniques n'ont connu que cette reine
et on est face à l'inconnu aussi que
représentera ce ce nouveau roi malgré
son âge déjà avancé 74 ans dans quelques
jours jéréy vous avez vu la la statue
devantquelle vient de passer le le
cercueil bien sûr de de Churchill et
donc ces funérailles aussi ont constitué
un événement national et on voit que de
cérémonie en cérémonie c'est toujours
comme disait georgeell tout peut changer
en Angleterre mais ce sera toujours le
même animal
[Musique]
et on voit comme ça la reine bien sûr
connaissait personnellement Wiston
Churchill depuis qu'elle était
petite et elle est aussi elle-même
aujourd'hui elle était le symbole de
l'esprit de on peut dire de Résistance
pendant la deuxème guerre mondiale comme
Churchill donc l'histoire est est on est
non seulement en train de tourner une
page de l'histoire mais on a tout le
livre devant
[Musique]
nousip jelli l'Écosse on a commencé à en
parler ensemble oui il faut rassurer les
pays du commonwes de l'autre côté de
l'Atlantique de l'autre côté du
Pacifique et cetera et cetera mais il
faut peut-être aussi
rassurer le Royaume-Uni et la
Grande-Bretagne
oui le cas de l' de l'Écosse va d'abord
de échoir à la première ministre leus
c'est c'est avant tout un dossier
politique qui est beaucoup plus li les
enjeux peut-être pour que tout le monde
saisisse bien ce qui passe avec l'c
l'écos c'est simple en deux mots
l'Écosse aurait voté a voté pour rester
dans l'Union européenne et le reste du
royaume a décidé le brexit donc donc
toute une partie des des des ennuis en
particulier économiques auquel est
confronté le Royaume-Uni aujourd'hui et
on il faut garder à l'esprit que là on a
les ors et la pompe mais demain on
annonce une récession le pays est déjà
frappé par une inflation très forte
autour de 10 % et les pour les factures
de chauffage l'hiver prochain ça
s'annonce très très très très douloureux
pour les foyers il y a un plan de d'aide
de 100 milliards de livres qui est
préparé par la première ministre le
trust mais qui n'a du fait du décès de
la reine qui n'a pas pu être débattu à
la Chambre des communes et qui n'a donc
pas encore été voté la séance est arrêté
au beau milieu he voilà et qui n'entrera
pas en vigueur le 1er octobre comme
c'était
prévu donc le le le débat sur
l'Écosse bon ça dépend d'abord des
Écossais il faut organiser un nouveau
référ ah oui alors parce qu'en 2014 il y
a eu un référendum 55 % des Écossais ont
voté pour l'intégrité du royaume euh
c'était James Camron qui était premier
ministre à l'époque et il avait demandé
plus ou moins à la reine d'Angleterre un
geste même si elle doit évidemment
rester en en retrait elle aurait dit et
et je cite euh que les gens réfléch
doivent réfléchir très attentivement à
l'avenir du royaume à l'époque
subtilement préserver cette unité elle
n'est plus là aujourd'hui est-ce que le
roi Charles peut et bien faire garder
ses C 5 % qui permettent à l'écos de ne
pas devenir indépendant c'est un immense
défi pour lui il succède à une monarque
qui a incarné évidemment non seulement
la monarchie mais son pays et qui n'a
jamais fait le moindre faux pas en 7
décennies c'est loin d'être le cas
de de Charles lorsqu'il était prince
héritier n'est-ce pas puisqu'il a
exprimé beaucoup d'opinions personnelles
il n'a pas il n'a pas eu la réserve que
que la reine estimait devoir observer il
promet
maintenant de d'adopter cette attitude
et d'avoir la même réserve mais on
connaît ces opinions très tranchées et
et parfois à contrecourant sur beaucoup
de sujets le climat
l'agriculture enfin il y a tout un tas
de sujets qui le passionnent
l'architecture peut-être que le climat
qui est une cause au-dessus du champ
politique ça ça peut être peut-être
l'une des des clés il peut dans ces
réunions hebdomadaire que le roi aura
avec sa première ministre c'est pas du
tout indifférent qu'elle débute aussi
dans la fonction il débutent tous les
deux dans cette fonction euh
probablement ne sa serura-t-on jamais ce
qui se passe dans leurs entretiens comme
on a jamais su jamais rien niltré de ce
que la reine et ses premiers ministres
nombreux pouvait se dire on a tout juste
su qu'elle n'aimait pas trop Tony Blair
parce qu'elle le trouvait elle avait
l'impression qu'il l'a roulé un peu dans
la farine que tout était toujours
parfait tout allait toujours très bien
se passer mais à part ce genre de de de
Demi indiscrétion phipe est-ce que vous
avez lu ce matin le le l'article
d'Arnaud de larand justement làdessus
vous le conseil dans le Figaro c'est
très très intéressant sur ces rapports
entre les Premier ministre et la reine
absolument absolument et on apprend
beaucoup de choses c'est plein
d'anecdotes mais il reste le fait que
sur la la la la teneur des échanges
politiques qu'ils peuvent avoirin la
reine peut conseiller mettre en garde
euh mais elle ne encourager et
encourager voilà ce sont les trois
formules mais elle ne peut pas aller
plus loin et surtout pas en public
Hélène est-ce qu'il a réussi ses débuts
le roi Charles apparemment oui il
convainc pour l'instant est-ce qu'il va
réussir à rester neutre comme l'été sa
mère en fait tout le tout dépend de la
durée du fameux pour l'instant
effectivement ses premiers déplacements
se sont bien passé y compris des
déplacements un peu redoutés comme celui
en Irlande du Nord où la situation là
aussi est tendue puisque irlandais du
Nord attendent une sortie de de la crise
dans à cause des accords douiniers post
brexit ça s'est plutôt bien passé on a
vu on l'a commenté plusôt les les codes
de popularité continuent de grimper y
compris en France a il y a toujours des
sortes d'état de grâce la question c'est
combien de temps cela va-t-il durer
est-ce que bon il y a y a une autre
échéance qui va nous retenir dans
quelques semaines quelques mois c'est
évidemment son couronnement donc on peut
lui souhaiter que cet état de grâce dure
au moins jusqu'au couronnement après
bien malin qui saurait le dire Jérémy
vous avez appelé vos amis votre
famille au Royaume-Uni il en pensent
quoi de ce roi Charles et vous-même
d'ailleurs je pense que justement comme
le disait helè les premières réactions
sont très positives
et et d'ailleurs c'est quelqu'un qu'on
connaît déjà et dont on connaît déjà un
peu les les les les failles et les
fautes là où il y aura un un grand défi
c'est que en fait la reine
elle elle exerçait une influence sur le
les premierers ministrees parce que on a
plusieurs témoignages à cet ég elle
connaissait les dossiers aussi bien
sinon mieux que ah parce qu'elle était
là depuis plus longtemps non elle était
là mais elle lisait tout elle avait une
mémoire et une capacité de travail
remarquable si Charle a ces mêmes
capacités il va faire un peu non pas tr
tremblé mais il va faire réfléchir un
peu les parce que si un un premier
ministre arrive il va dire ah je c que
s'il peut citer des faits non pas des
opinions mais des faits j'ai lu dans le
document numéro 3 paragraphe C et ce
s'il est capable de faire ça il va avoir
une influence il a cette réputation le
roi le roi charâ a la réputation d'être
de lire beaucoup d'être très bien
informé sur tout un tas de dossiers par
contre il a aussi la réputation d'être
assez impatient ouais
et et d'être capable de s'enflammer pour
des causes on a beaucoup glosé sur
l'incident du stylo vous avez peut-être
vu sans faire de la psychologie du du
stylo c'est c'est voilà on voit qu'il
peut être impatient et parfois perdre
effectivement son son s alors certains
disent qu'ussi il a il a toujours été un
enfant gâté quoi c'est la
la sa position veut ça et et que il a on
lui connait des petites manies il a un
Vallet qui étale la la le dentifrice sur
sa sur sa brosse à dent qui repasse
c'est pas forcément très bien vu
çaimagine va réduire le train de vie
apparemment de la maison royale en
notamment en limitant le nombre de
d'employés à pleintemps si vous voulez
de figures représentative officielle de
la monarchie qui sont aujourd'hui une
quinzaine
EMB brigadé enfin qui qui qui représente
la monarchie dans quelques
3000 causes et évén chaque année donc
réduire le train de vie de la maison
royale pour la rendre plus légitime plus
acceptable moins un sujet de polémique
il y a aussi évidemment un danger qui
est de la rendre moins visible or comme
vous l'avez dit on cite l'excellent
Walter blagerhot si je ne m'abuse qui
est cité par Arnaud de Lagrand B
par faites bien nous reprendre sur notre
accent vous êtes le meilleur C unf Pr
même pour un anglais j'ai des décennies
àend il devait avoir des origines
françaises et
une qui disait que pour exister la
monarchie a besoin d'être vu et pour
être accepté elle est vu alors
aujourd'hui elle est vue aujourd'hui par
peut-être vous verront les chiffres 4
milliards de personnes imaginé Jérémy où
est-on là exactement dans dans
Londres si
je là je pense que le mal c'est ça mal
on on nit pas cette partie là c'est
c'est c'est c'est la fin de la
procession donc là soudain on est avec
le cercueil on est dans toujours dans
Whitehall me semble-t-il d'après la
statue qui est derrière si on voit bien
donc la la la la voilà c'est ça on voit
ça c'est le derrière je pense c'est le
le scénotaap où il y a les cérémonies on
nom des des
guerres
et on va
bientô de Buckingham c'est ça petit à
petit petit à petit mais pas encore on
est pas
encore on va tourner à gauche là on vit
un instant ce qu'il se passe dans les
dans les rues de Londres et puis on
revient en direct la foule a l'air
silencieuse n pas ENF on entend la
musique
[Musique]
on resserre les rangs pour passer sous
hosgards c'est ça Jérémy studs oui
rosgard et le le terrain de parade après
là ah le terrain de parade d'accord
voilà ça c'est le terrain de parade ah
oui je je me souviens d'avoir vu
beaucoup d'images lors du jubilé
notamment exactement les les manœuvres
ont lieu là il y a une sorte de copie du
xénotap derrière et le Parc de St James
et du côté où nous sommes c'est
l'améroté nous découvrons Londres avec
vous Jérémy Philippe la foule semble
silencieuse baisse la tête presque
devant le le passage du Cercil oui
apparemment autant qu'on puisse en juger
parce que il y a la musique couvre
peut-être des saluts ou des
maisif la musique et vous venez
d'entendre sil y avait de forts
applaudissements je pense qu'on les
entendrait et je pense que donc le
silence et le recueillement domine et
intervalle régulier on vient de
l'entendre Philippe le coup de canon à H
Park et big men qui qui sonne hein tout
ça est calibré les hommages d'un d'un
peuple à une reine Hélène on a du mal à
imaginer ça en France mais ça a toujours
été le cas dans l'histoire c'est les
manifestations même en France les
derniersres funérailles nationales en
Angleterre c'est c'est Churchill he
c'est 1965 euh en France il faut creuser
un petit peu pour trouver des
équivalents évidemment on va penser au
général de Gaulle pour avoir une stature
qui a un petit
peu le le le même niveau entre
guillemets bon là si on se creuse un
petit peu on va tomber sur les
funérailles de johnnyidday c'est quand
même pas tout à fait la même chose même
s'il y avait eu évidemment un engouement
populaire très fort à ce moment-là euh
le le décorum n'est pas du tout le même
ça c'est évident et on n pas des on n
pas strict au sensus on n pas
d'équivalent par exemple en France
depuis Louis XIV exactement ce que
j'allais vous dire à la mort de Louis
XIV comment la France a réagi est-ce
qu'on s'en souvient est-ce qu'on le sait
alors le à partir du moment où il y a
pas de médiatisation c'est difficile à
dire évidemment le le cérémonial est
très important à à Paris vous avez alors
aujourd'hui on a du mal à imaginer mais
en fait tout ce qui représente la rue
Saint-Denis la rue Saint-Jacques la rue
Saint-Denis dans le centre de Paris
était ce qu'on appelait la voie royale
qui permettait de monter après jusqu'à
la basilique de Saint-Denis et donc il y
avait un cortège royal qui traversait
toute la capitale et qui devait donner
probablement l'occasion à des à des
rassemblements tels que celui-ci mais on
n pas évidemment de d'image le corp de1
a été transporté comme ça de Versailles
jusqu'à la basilique de saintd donc ça
fait quand même un ça fait quand même un
certain chemin exactement très étonnant
pas été le cas pour 175 1715 ce n'a pas
été le cas pour Louis XV pour le coup
qui étant foncièrement impopulaire a eu
droit à un cortège nocturne donc pour
éviter les débordements et Louis XIV qui
a ne parlons pas de Louis X ne parlons
pas de Louis 16
qui aé plus longtemps plus longtemps
exactement alors sur les réseaux sociaux
les les Français s'en réjouissent en
disant que le Roi Soleil détient
toujours le record 72 ans effectivement
alors les Anglais quand même disent oui
mais pour la reine Élisabeth c'est 70
ans sans Régence ce qui n pas faux
puisqueeffectivement dans le cas de
Louis XIV les 72 ans ça inclus sa
régence donc régence de sa mère en
l'occurrence donc le record est encore
objet de débart Philippe j'ai demandé à
ce que vous veniez sur ce plateau pour
parler évidemment de la laaren c'est une
portée internationale pour parler de ce
rassemblement des grands dirigeants de
ce monde on les a quasiment pas vu Pasu
pas prix si je dire Joe Biden Emmanuel
Macron ça eu que je pense en premier il
y a aussi bolsonaro par exemple qui
était ici le président brésilien on ne
les voit pas du tout je pense que pour
ces dirigeants en tout cas pour pour un
certain nombre d'entre eux il y a un
enjeu de politique intérieure tout
simplement d'abord à être invité ensuite
à être présent don léitimité bolsonaro
il est en campagne électorale il y a des
élections début octobre au Brésil
ilambassade il a fait un discours depuis
le balcon de l'ambassade alors du Brésil
au Royaume-Uni et il est il est il est
en mauvaise posture dans les sondages
face à Loula toute occasion de
s'affirmer je dirais pacifiquement comme
le le détenteur du pouvoir reconnu comme
tel par la communauté internationale
c'est c'est du bénéfice pour lui donc
c'est c'est c'est assez compréhensible
qu'il ait fait le voyage Joe Biden c'est
évidemment pour d'autres raisons c'est
c'est
l'entente la relation spéciale entre les
le Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis la
proximité de de des deux pays et aussi
l'importance que revit aux États-Unis le
fait d'être invité par la
reine rappelez-vous les visites de
Donald Trump
à à
Londres il a il a fait pas mal de de
gaffe dans le protocole marchant devant
la reineant ça déboutonné et cetera et à
la fin il s'est justifié en disant
qu'elle avait plus rigoler avec lui que
depuis 25
ans c'est SRA vous savez qu'on s'est
posé la question à un moment de savoir
s'il serait invité ou pas parce que le
président des États-Unis avait la
faculté d'inviter certains des anciens
présidents d'accord donc Obama le nom
des Obamas venait à l'esprit en premier
mais pourquoi pas George Bush aussi et
alors se poser la question de Trump je
crois qu'il a il a jugé plus sage de
n'en inviter aucun demain autre
événement international qui débute à
l'ONU eu c'est ou ce petit monde prend
l'avion dans la foulée et va à New York
pour l'Assemblée générale de l'ONU
évidemment c'est là-bas qu'on fait de la
la politique internationale c'est pas
auprès du du cercueil de de la reine
ellisabeth même si le roi Charles a reçu
dimanche soir tous ses invités de marque
étrangers pour une réception euh dans le
cas de du président Macron ils se
connaissent déjà ils se sont rencontrés
lors du 70e anniversaire du ou 70e
anniversaire je crois du did du 18 juin
euh ils ont eu une conversation enfin je
j'en ai parl avec des des responsables
de l'Élysée apparemment le courant est
bien passé entre les deux mais euh je ne
crois pas que aucun de ces invités
d'abord ils sont trop nombreux pour ça
et pu faire avancer le moindre dossier à
la faveur de ce de de ce funéraal c'est
pas le sujet il y aura une réunion entre
Biden et trus et là à mon avis il vont
parler de l'Irlande du Nord entre autres
choses euh pourquoi parce que bid est
irlandais voilà ou ou d'origine
d'origine il est aussi de Régine
française mais il n'en parle pas je c
française aussi il avait Joe Robinette
Biden Robinette et Normand il me semble
he donc il a des europé ououi mais aux
États-Unis en prétexte toutes sortes
d'origine mais oui l'Irlande du Nord il
s'agit du protocole et là on est
toujours sur le dossier du brexit il
n'en finit pas h
et c'est curieux parce que il y a il n'y
a pas si longtemps on a eu le brexit et
maintenant on a eu cette cérémonie quel
rapport entre les deux il beaucoup à
gloser là-dessus Hélène pardonnez mon
cynisme qui profite le plus entre
l'istrus et le gouvernement et la
royauté de toutes ces personnalités qui
viennent à Londres pour cet événement de
portée mondiale alors comme on le disait
à l'instant les chefs d'État ils sont là
parce qu'ils doivent faire acte de
présence mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
vont en profiter tant que ça je pense
que l'istreus va vraiment en profiter
parce que elle a quand même été l'une
des dernières si je puis dire à avoir ir
serrer la main de la reine dans des dans
ses fonctions officielles ça va lui
forcément lui donner un capital de
sympathie pour les pour les prochains
mois alors même qu'elle est quand même
arrivée dans un dans un contexte tendu
les débats au sein du Parti conservateur
n'ont pas été évidents entre elle et son
et son rival donc ça cela va lui lui
bénéficier indéiablement et puis
évidemment la la famille royale les les
codes de popularité sont là pour sont là
pour nous le dire 13h48 nous sommes
toujours en direct sur le plateau de
figure live et à Londres
où est-on dans Londres
dites-moi là d'après ce que je vois le
cercueil est
sur d'accord on
est la grande avenue qui monte
vers le
palais et ça procède lentement mais
inexorablement et on va pouvoir voir et
tout au fond
làckingam
absolument
et on va contourner le l'espèce de
rondpoint et ensuite verer sur le côté
du palais pour atteindre l'arc du duc de
Wellington qui qui avait sa maison par
là
et son adresse quand il habitait c'est
au coin de H Park c'était numéro 1
Londres c'est son adresse vous voyez ici
la reine qu'on sort Camila ainsi que
Kate Middleton il me semble ou il est
peut-être le le Prince George aussi dans
dans cette dans cette voiture nous
restons évidemment en direct et on
s'imprègne de l'ambiance à
[Musique]
Londres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Hélène dein est-ce que une journée comme
celle-ci est une journée de deuil ou
d'une certaine manière une journée de
fête et de célébration alors aujourd'hui
je pense quand même que le sentiment de
de deuil et de peine l'emporte et la
gravité des images qu'on a vu le le
silence qu'on notait tout à l'heure sont
là pour en témoigner néanmoins le
l'espoir n'est jamais très loin alors
nous nous discutions tout à l'heure sur
le le couplet du Gods de Queen ou Gods
the king si no notre audition a été la
bonne et bien finalement ce champ résume
bien le le passage de témoins donc oui
c'est ça alors ça a commencé il nous a
semblé que ça le premier couplet était
avec Queen et le second avec King c'est
ça demande à être vérifié mais toujours
est-il que effectivement l'espoir n'est
jamais très loin mais bon clairement
aujourd'hui c'est quand même c'est quand
même l'émotion et le deuil qui qui
domine vous en pensez quoi Jérémy c'est
une fête ou non pas tant ça pas encore
pour être encore pour pour être vraiment
prétentieux ou on peut dire qu'il y a
une forme de sacré là devant nous je
crois pas que vous êtes prétentieux là
c'est clairement on tourne autour du
sacré pendant pendant cette cérémonie et
ces finunéraill vous me réconfortez là
mais en fait euh dans la mesure où à
l'époque moderne il y a un
sacré en dehors de
l'église voilà ce sacré et ça ça impose
toute une série d'émotions très
mélangées on voit enfin les
applaudissements qui
commencent on avait dit qu'on serait
entre le la tristesse et une forme de
joie ou au moins de d'expression de
reconnaissance c'est ce ce ce
cocktail enivrant on peut dire d'émotion
qui qui est servi aujourd'hui moi je
pense que sont les deux en effet oui le
le le deuil le recueillement mais aussi
je pense que tous ces gens qui sont
sortis de chez eux qui sont venus sur
ces kilomètres de parcours veulent avant
tout accompagner la reine et il y a
quelque chose de très chaleureux dans le
fait qu'il soit là et
donc je suis certain et les échos qu'on
a de nos envoyés spéciaux c'est que ça
n'est pas une tristesse un accablement
qui domine dans dans dans la foule non
c'est cette espèce de communion avec une
dame qui a donné sa vie à son pays et à
ses
fonction quand même très lourde
euh forme l'expression d'une
reconnaissance mais de manière je crois
assez chaleureuse pardà le le le rit qui
est lui-même très formel je pense qu'il
y a on faisait tout à l'heure le
parallèle avec les événements de 97 il y
a pas de comparaison possible en terme
de sentiment clairement parce
qu'effectivement
97 c'était un accident c'était une
tragédie c'était la perte d'une personne
qui avait noué des liens affectifs très
forts avec la population tout à fait
Diana et et du coup il y avait vraiment
le sentiment de la perte d'une perte
irremplaçable pour beaucoup de pour
beaucoup de Britanniques et au-delà
tandis que là effectivement il y a une
perte mais une perte qui est naturelle
on arrive à la fin d'un processus et la
place si je puis dire est tout de suite
occupé par par son fils qui prend prend
la relève donc le deuil ne prend pas le
même la même teinte de d'affliction que
qu'à cette époque oui Philippe moi je
trouve que enfin je suis frappé par le
fait que vous avez raison tout cela
était absolument dans l'ordre des choses
prévu de longues dates personne ne s'est
autant préparé au métier de roi que
Charles
iapentissage de cette décenni mais mais
nous sommes malgré tout devant les mêmes
incertitudes la même sensation de de de
possibl précipices ou enfin peut-être le
mot est trop fort de mais il y a quand
même un vide à remplir il y a un vide à
remplir il y a une inconnue énorme sur
la façon dont le nouveau roi va régner
euh dont la il va réussir ou pas à faire
évoluer la monarchie puisque on sait
qu'une de ces un de ses objectifs c'est
de la moderniser qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire tout le monde dit qu'il sera un roi
de transition qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
euh est-ce qu'on peut être un roi de
transition pendant 20 ans 25 ans selon
euh la durée de vie qui lui sera prêtée
euh beaucoup d'attentes en fait sont
déjà reportées sur William euh
l'héritier du du nouveau roi on dit que
le nouveau roi va davantage s'appuyer
sur son fils que le faisait la reine
avec char enfin il y a toutes ces
inconnus euh y compris d'ailleurs sur
euh la personnalité du du roi puisqueon
on l'a dit tout à l'heure en tant que
Prince il a créé des polémiques il ne
faisait pas l'unanimité rappelez-vous
qu'avant le décès de la reine Élisabeth
sa code de popularité éit à 39 % très
faible aujourd'hui en l'espace de 2
semaines elle est à 63 %. et quand on
veut juger pardon de de de ces premier
pas là on a presque un plébiscite 73 %.
39 ce serait pas mauvais pour un homme
politique qui dire oui vous il en a
certains qui en avoir
aant oui oui tout à fait tout à fait en
en fait euh ce qui est intéressant c'est
que Charles et William vont sans doute
présenter un front commun beaucoup plus
qu'Élisabeth et Charles ouais euh et en
fait finalement ellisabeth n'a pas eu
besoin pendant des années de de Charles
et à la fin il était peut-être déjà trop
tard alors que là il sait que tout de
suite William est populaire il peut s'en
servtir aussi fa tout à fait en fait le
modèle qu' a créé la reine Victoria
c'est LE modèle de la famille ce qui
compte c'est la famille royale elisabeth
a promu le même modèle dans les années
50 et 60 et puis tout s'est effondré
avec les divorces les scandales et donc
elle a dû recentrer la monarchie sur
elle-même vraiment sur sa personne pour
tout reconstruire c'est ça le le le une
des grandes
réalisations et bien Charles s'il peut
revenir à à l'idée de la famille de la
famille et du du du Père et du Fils ce
sera grâce à à à sa mère mais aussi un
grand changement on parlait du deuil et
pourquoi pas de la fête il y aura une
fête parce qu'il y aura un couronnement
évidemment est-ce que déjà on a une idée
de la date Jérémie et est-ce que on peut
avoir à nouveau et bien la même ferveur
populaire est-ce que Joe Biden est-ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron seront invité est-ce
qu'il le autant de monondre dans les
rues mais en fait là on
est au début de l'automne on n pas
encore
souffert tout ce qu'on
va souffrir cet hiver tout dépendra de
de de l'humour de l'humeur pardon de
l'humeur populaire et je dirais que joli
lapsus si oui tout à fait exactement si
tout se passe mal politiquement au cours
de l'hiver on va peut-être remettre le
sacre
pour plus tard pour les beau jours si
jamais il sera remis au beau jour hein
on parle du Printemps du début de l'été
pas avant d'abord on est il y a une
période de deuil qui doit être respecté
donc ça nous amène à j'imagine plus de
40 jours je parle des des beau jours
autant au sens politiqueou vous avez
tout à fait raison co après une fois les
les fastes des célébrations passées les
les Anglais les Britanniques vont
retomber dans le dur avec un hiver qui
s'annonce très difficile une situation
économique qui qui qui est quand même
très dur et on n'est pas du tout à
l'abri de mouvements sociaux eux-mêm
assez assez dur alors organiser bon le
le délai normal qui prévoit que le
couronnement de Charles doiv avoir lieu
au printemps ou au début de l'été est
lié à la durée du deuil et à la la
complexité des préparatifs de du
couronnement lui-même mais il peut être
impacté cette date peut être impactée
par la situation sociale dans le pays
s'il y avait une
agitation qui qui rende si vous voulez
presque obsè entre guillemets le fait
d'organiser une célébration de ce type
donc ça va être un calcul assez subtil
mais c'est très politique avec une
instabilité politique on sait que depuis
le brexit il y a déjà eu quatre premiers
ministres au Royaume-Uni est-ce que
est-ce que le Royaume-Uni va s'unir
comme ça semble être le cas depuis 10
jours et PhIP en parler un instant ou
est-ce que il peut y avoir une forme de
déchirure à présent plus rien ne tient
parce que la reine n'est plus là c'est
un risque je pense qu'on a tendance un
peu en France à le surestimer ce risque
mais
euh et que bon on aime bien publier des
sondages sur la popularité de la
monarchie et de se dire oh finalement
est-ce que les Anglais il tiennent tant
que ca et cetera je pense qu'il faut pas
surestimer ce risque maintenant il est
évident que la la figure fédératrice de
la reine n'est plus là donc il y a une
part d'incertitude mais bon ça reste
quand même enfin l'attachement tradition
des Britanniques qui est quand même
extrêmement puiss cette cérémonie fait
beaucoup pour réhabiliter si elle en
avait besoin l'institution de la
monarchie elle elle montre que ça
fonctionne parfaitement et qu'elle est
en symbiose avec la population donc je
dirais que quand vous avez c'est la
partie du PAI qui marche le mieux en ce
moment quand vous avez des gens qui sont
capables de faire 35 heur de queue c'est
que ils y sont attachés quand même donc
donc il est évident que s'imaginer que
tout pourrait se découdre ou se se
dissoudre à peine les les les
funérailles terminés non pas du tout
mais il y a un il y a des processus il y
a des des tensions des jeux de force qui
sont à l'œv depuis un certain temps qui
vont sans doute se poursuivre et là la
personnalité la capacité du nouveau roi
d'unifier d'unir de représenter toutes
les toutes les facettes de son royaume
de ses royaumes et on on sait qui on dit
et on sait qu'il est très attaché à
cette
diversité joueront un rôle important il
est 14h1 minute nous sommes en direct
sur le figure live Philippe Gell j'ai
une dernière question pour vous les
liens avec la France comment va se
positionner la francien est-ce que pour
Emmanuel Macron il est plus important de
recevoir listrus ou ou Charles I est-ce
qu'on a une ID les deux mon général je
pense que on peut pas faire l'impasse
sur le nouveau roi je pense que c'est
utile
d'avoir d'avoir une ligne de d'abord je
crois que Charles aime la France comme
sa mère
l'aimait on remarque que l'Élysée a
beaucoup communiqué sur les nombreuses
visites de la reine en France sur le
fait qu'elle parlait français sur le
fait qu'elle aimait la
France on espère je je crois dans dans
dans les instances dirigeantes
françaises qu'il en ira de même avec le
avec le roi parce que on voit le roi à
tort ou à raison comme un élément
stabilisateur dans la durée alors que
comme vous l'avez dit on change de
Premier ministre tous les tous les 8
mois en ce moment au Royaume-Uni donc
euh c'est important d'avoir de des
relations solides stables et les plus
ouvertes possible avec le monarque mais
la politique est faite au Royaume-Uni
par le Premier ministre et donc je ne
crois pas que l'Élysée fera l'impasse
sur Madame th
h Wellington arch nous venons de de voir
les images et ça y est le cercueil qui
s'approche donc de de son de son point
d'arrivée hein puisque à partir de
Wellington arch ce cercueil qui est et
pour l'instant sur cette affu canon
mythique sera
transposé transporté dans une limousine
un corbiard en direction de Winsor on
suivra ça évidemment toute la journée
sur le Figaro live merci à vous de
m'avoir accompagné merci beaucoup hline
de loszin merci beaucoup jéristubs merci
beaucoup Philippe jelli on reste en
direct hein les images vous les suivez
avec cette ambiance ce grand mouvement
cette grande manifestation qui est
devenue populaire maintenant que le
cercueil d'Élizabeth est dans les vous
restez avec nous sur le Figaro live
merci de nous avoir
[Musique]
suivi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
for
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]